it's been a pretty brutal start to the
year Italy the worst start that China
could have possibly second largest
economy or a weekly loss in okla
Fester's losing confidence what's going
on the charger Bank excited problems in
Chinese shine app China China China
China okay here's an econ 101 version of
what's going on in China the world's
second-biggest economy has suddenly gone
from an engine of world economic growth
to the caboose true it's still growing
faster than the US but it's a big drop
from just a few years ago and for
markets it's a change in the growth rate
that matters more than the level of
growth investments that made sense when
China is going ten percent or more a
year don't make sense when growth is
below seven percent understandably
foreign investors are getting cold feet
and they're not putting nearly as much
money into China meanwhile residents of
China are taking much more money out of
the country so how does all that affect
the world slower growth means a smaller
appetite for raw materials like oil and
copper less money in China means the
Chinese have less buying power and
China's neighbors will be among the most
affected countries for the u.s. American
companies don't ship a lot of their
goods to China less than one percent of
gross domestic product so Americans are
relatively insulated American banks are
also not highly exposed to China in part
because China hasn't left them very far
in still it wouldn't be a good thing for
Western banks if companies that do
business with China suffered losses and
some of them defaulted on their loans
growth worries have cratered the Chinese
stock market Chinese President Xi
Jinping is struggling to stop the
turmoil but the Communist Party's fixes
aren't working that's a problem since
ultimately the only country that can fix
China's problems is China itself